hi all Jenny here before we get started
I want to share with you some of the
latest offerings from Stamford GSB
Executive Education in 2024 they will be
offering some pretty exciting programs
including harnessing AI for breakthrough
Innovation and strategic impact the
Innovative Healthcare leader and the
Asian leadership program the application
window is open now to learn more go to
grow. stanford.edu
upcoming many of us dread meetings in
our first of two episodes on making
meetings meaningful we learned best
practices from academics on how to be
better in meetings in our second episode
you'll learn even more techniques for
bringing people together figuring out
the best way to maximize our time and
making your meetings more
effective some of the brightest spots in
my day or when I receive an email that
says a meeting has been
cancelled this is not a good thing
meetings are important and can be very
helpful yet many are ineffective in a
waste of time by focusing on purpose and
outcome we can make meetings matter I'm
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart
the
podcast today I am really looking
forward to speaking with Alise Keith
alely is a friend and a very creative
thinker when it comes to making meetings
more effective Alise is also known as
the meeting Maven and co-founded Lucid
meetings and wrote where the action is
the meetings that make or break your
organization I'm excited to have you
help us crack the code on effective
meetings Elise
welcome thank you for having me l do it
Elise in your opinion what are meetings
good for everything in an organizations
communication architecture is really
designed to channel three things right
we're channeling information we're
channeling attention and we're driving
intent so of all of the communication
channels we have so your email and your
slack and your asynchronous work and
whatnot meetings are really the most
powerful one
So when you say what are meetings good
for right it's the one place where
you've got the entire group's attention
focused on the same information at the
same time and you can channel that into
Clarity of intent on what happens next
so it's powerful SO meetings are really
powerful that way absolutely they're a
way of focusing and really making sure
that people are aligned I appreciate
that when is it best to run your
meetings in person vers versus virtually
the short answer is how well do you know
your group mhm right and how clear are
you on what you're trying to achieve and
if the answer is I don't really know
this group very well and we're not super
clear on what we need to do your odds of
getting a good result are better if
you're in person because when things are
wishy-washy and messy being in the room
so that we can interrupt each other and
overlap and read that body language
really really well helps that said if
you are super clear on what you need to
achieve and how you're going to do it
you can use that intentionality to be
successful in any format excellent so it
really has to do with how well you know
each other as at least an initial
decision point for deciding virtual or
in person how well you know each other
and also how clear you are about what
you need to accomplish right absolutely
now I know in your work you distinguish
among a variety of different types of
meetings can you give us a rundown on a
few of these different types yeah you
bet what we discovered is that across
all of the business functions leadership
to you know onboarding your frontend
customer support there are essentially
16 different types of meetings that can
be grouped into three rough categories
so there are these Cadence meetings
which are the ones that we use to keep
work going we've got a team we know what
we're trying to achieve and we need to
get together to make sure that we're
actually making progress and that
nothing too big has changed you know are
you still okay are we still doing the
right thing those are your Cadence
meetings there are a whole another set
of meetings called The Catalyst meetings
and those are about changing things
brainstorming decisions problem solving
and for those you're going to want to
bring together the right people to help
you achieve that goal and follow a
process that helps that group think
about the problem in the same way at the
same time so that's really where all
that facilitation stuff comes in is in
those kinds of places and then the final
set that other last bit is what we call
learn and influence and shashir maroda
at Kota who's done a beautiful job
looking at this from the startup Valley
perspective calls context so in essence
what do we do how do we gather to help
give people an understanding of how to
make sense of what's going on for our
organization right now and how we can
better think about the work that we do
together Cadence Catalyst and context
are the big buckets of different types
of meetings and I think that's really
important for people to understand what
the purpose of the meeting is so that
you can better design the meeting to fit
that purpose do you have advice and
guidance on finding purpose and
articulating that so people are focused
on what is going on or will be going on
in the
meetings absolutely Ely the way to think
about it is this there are two things
you need to know before you schedule any
meeting one is the purpose and one is
the outcomes so what will be different
because we did this and with the purpose
you want to state that is a verb and
here's a rule that verb has to be
something like to decide to create a
plan to make sense of to find an
agreement and it cannot include any
words that are a synonym for meeting so
give me an example of what a good
meeting purpose statement would be well
let's talk about the common example in
companies where they might say hey
there's a budget meeting on the calendar
so meeting is a synonym for meeting
pretty a pretty direct one and budget is
a noun not a verb what is the purpose of
that meeting no clue something related
to the budget so what do you break it
down well if it were a planning meeting
it would be to create the budget plan
for next quarter if it's a
problemsolving meeting it would be to
solve the budget shortfall if it's a
decision-making meeting Perhaps it is to
approve the budget changes that came
from our
departments love it that's really
practical and tactical elas the second
thing you mentioned Beyond purpose was
focusing on outcomes can you tell us
more so if our purpose is to make a plan
or to approve that decision the outcome
will be very naturally a decision
an ideally a documented decision and
then what else you know what else needs
to come from that meeting so that the
meeting has injected the intention the
energy into your system to get that job
done so in the case of a decision-making
meeting it'll be our plan for how we're
going to communicate this decision to
the rest of the
organization this really nicely doves
tailes what we talked about when we
talked with Karen Reed and Joe Allen we
were talking about setting agendas and
and the importance of having agendas and
they both advise that having a clear
purpose is really important more so than
actually the itemized agenda and you
helped us and I appreciate this to best
understand what that purpose should
sound like have it be a verb and make
sure that you don't have any synonyms
for the word meeting in there and I
think that makes it much clearer and it
also helps you I would assume and I'd
love your opinion on this to assess the
success of the meeting if you have a
clear purpose you can then judge the
success of it because a lot of meetings
I come out of I'm not clear one why we
met and then two were we successful
agendas are a mixed bag I have really
mixed feelings about recommending people
always pay attention to agendas I think
there are much better approaches and
better ways to think about meeting
success than that but with purpose and
outcome you put those things in the
calendar in advance people know should I
be in that room how do I prepare am I
equipped to help us get to that result
it's it that's all you need a lot of the
time I am smiling earto ear because you
mentioned the calendar invite I feel
like the calendar invite is the most
underutilized tool for helping us have
effective meetings for the very reason
you mentioned it helps us get prepared
it sets our expectations we can put in
those invites so many useful things just
what you call your meeting matters just
as you said how you label your purpose
so I really encourage people to take
what Alisa is saying to heart and really
think about how you can operationalize
it in your meeting invites so Elise I
get that purpose and outcome are really
important to Define upfront to have a
successful meeting I'm curious as you
begin to think through your purpose of
meeting and your potential outcome are
there times where you might decide that
a meeting isn't the most effective way
to come together and accomplish this
purpose and if so what do you advise
people to do when thinking about not
meeting the answer is embedded in the
question if you are unclear what the
purpose is do not hold other people's
time hostage other people's time is not
for you to sit there and work out what
that might be that you are not ready to
meet do not meet if you don't know what
the purpose is instead step back maybe
send an email maybe use slack maybe talk
to your dog go for a walk get clear if
you are are clear on the purpose you're
clear on the outcomes but you can't get
the people who will help you achieve the
outcomes don't meet figure out how to
communicate with them in a way to get
that done so there's no reason to invite
people to have a conversation that they
then can't resolve that's enormously
frustrating and then finally if you show
up you know who's supposed to be there
you're clear on what to do you're clear
on what you're trying to achieve you get
there and then somebody doesn't show up
or yeah we all thought we would do this
but our dog died this morning like
whatever it is if you're not in a
position to actually be successful stop
you can't have a meeting of the minds if
the minds are not in the meeting if
they're like on their you know what they
just ran into or their their dry throat
or whatever yeah that's a a great way of
putting it how can you have meetings of
the minds if the minds aren't ready to
meet and this notion of being a steward
of people's time I think is really an
appropriate way to Envision meetings
meetings can be incredibly effective
uses of time you can really catalyze and
and initiate good work but at the same
time you can waste a lot of time and I
think the criteria that you gave us are
really helpful I have seen you run
meetings you're an expert facilitator
are there things that you tend to go to
to just get people to be engaged to get
them off their devices to get them off
of multitasking how can you pull people
into the content clearly making it
relevant and relying on best practices
that work for your team makes a lot of
sense but are there other tools or
experiences that you rely on to help
engage people yeah and certainly if
you're working with a group where you're
not so clear or you're a guest which I
happen to be a lot of the time as an
outside expert always show up a little
early show up in advance you know you
are hosting you are creating an
experience so make it welcoming say
hello right bring people in and there's
something about when you especially if
you're in a virtual setting but in any
setting when they see your face and you
talk to them right off the bat the you
set the expectation that hey guess what
you are here as a contributor I expect
you to talk and you want to back that up
by ensuring they are contributing in
some way within the first five minutes
so come up with activities and exercises
to get contribution and this touches on
a topic again that we spoke with Karen
and Joe about which is this notion of
equity you want to make sure that
everybody has at least an equal
opportunity to contribute it doesn't
mean everybody contributes equally but
that they have that opportunity and
especially in hybrid meetings where some
are in person and and some are virtual
that's important do you have specific
questions you ask or ground rules you
set up to help ensure that people do
participate early and often you know on
occasion I tend not to use ground rules
very often instead I work harder and I
recommend that people do things that
make it clear in the environment what
the natural behavior is so let's take an
early engagement thing that you can do
both with real teams that you work with
and then as an outside person walking to
lead a meeting first 5 minutes hey
everybody how you doing I want to check
that we're in good shape for this today
on a scale of zero to five has your
energy with zero being oh my gosh I'm
nearly dead and five being wo J hands
let's go you know and three like I'm
fine thanks let's move on 3 two 1 show
me how you're doing it's a visual we ask
people to hold up hands or type in the
chat mhm and we have this opportunity to
say okay hey guess what
I'm going to ask you things and you're
going to reply hey we're going to all do
it at once hey everybody's participating
hey a range of opinions is welcome right
so we do things to set the conditions
that make the kind of behavior that we
want to share collaboratively obvious
what is so cool about that bit of advice
that you just shared the example you
gave is not only does it get people
engaged and demonstrate that you want
them to be participating but you
actually get them doing it so you set
that expect
and with that one in particular you get
Vital Information that will help
influence how you proceed in that
meeting if everybody comes back a five
you're going to do things a little
differently than if you have mixed
results or a lower average in terms of
energy so I like that idea and instead
of saying this is a meeting where we all
will participate you actually do the
participation that I think is a really
valuable idea something I just learned
that I really like I was doing a
presentation and I asked people to share
their best practices they use for
meetings and somebody talked about sitb
back time and I thought this was
fascinating so in order to encourage
fingers off the keyboards on a virtual
meeting for example is they just say
it's sitb back time so everybody just
takes a seat back so their hands
literally can't reach the keyboard and
then they have their conversation that
way and anybody at any point can say
it's sitb back time and it's not seen as
being harsh or aggressive it's just
saying we really need to connect on this
particular issue and it's a nice way of
setting expectations and having a norm
for talking about really important
issues so I love these experiential ways
of inculcating behavior such that we can
actually drive success in those meetings
are there other tools that you use when
facilitating to bring about the
coordination and cooperation that we're
looking for paired with equity and
safety and just the time constraints
that go into meetings two that speak
Direct direct ly to what you're talking
about our think pair share or one two
all or whatever you want to call it
where you ask a critical question to the
group and then you give everybody a
minute to think about it on their own in
silence massive leveler right because
not everybody processes instantly also
by the way it keeps people who are
likely to say well let me talk to you
about this for 10 minutes there's no
space for that we're doing silent and
then after everybody has silent time to
think about it they turn to one or two
other people compare those ideas and in
the full group you invite those best
ideas to come out what is one thing that
came from your group that everybody else
needs to hear so everybody participates
but not everybody is put on the spot
where they have to share in front of
everyone else I love the think PA share
it is an excellent teaching technique it
is helpful for people who might be more
introverted or perhaps don't have the
same command of the language because
it's not their their first language it
gives an opportunity to reflect and then
to connect with others before you
actually bring to the table and the
thing that you highlighted there that
many of us don't think about is the
notion of Silence in meetings silence
can be productive time it can be time
where people are really doing active
work was there another one you wanted to
add in the business context is important
to remember that we also need to get
work done right meetings are about
achieving results you can use those same
techniques and take the time where the
group is working together through things
make it longer and Achieve basically
parallel processing so let me give you
an example let's say your leadership
team is working through what's going on
this month and you've run into a number
of issues that have come up that the
team needs to work through right we've
got some hiring delays we've got
something going on in the supply chain
we've got a customer who's got a problem
you know 10 things to work through well
if you keep the entire team together
talking through each of the 10 things
one at a time what happens you're there
till Tuesday Thursday it's the longest
meeting ever and you make no progress
because you don't have time to get any
of them done so instead you can have the
entire group silently rank which of
these are the top priorities and then
break that group up three people take
the first one three people take the
second one three people take the third
one and they work on them in parallel at
the same time coming to a suggested
resolution I like having people maximize
the productivity by splitting up and
having people focus on what's most
important right so meetings you have
this opportunity to divide the work but
not the team right we're working on this
all together and at the same time you're
doing this thing everybody's
contributing everybody has a chance to
have input everybody's valued and we're
making progress driving towards that
outcome you talked about more
efficiently so at least you are full of
lots of best practices if if you're okay
I'd like to do a lightning round if you
will of specific issues or challenges or
opportunities and I'd love just to get
your thought about one best practice for
each are you up for that bring it great
what's your best advice to empower
somebody to contribute in a meeting when
it's going hot and heavy lots of folks
are talking all at once how do you get
your voice heard in that moment parallel
processing parallel communication
channels so use the chat if you're in
online if you're in person write it down
and post it somewhere excellent I like
that my advice in that situation is to
paraphrase something that's being said
and use that as the hook that pulls you
into the conversation so you can latch
on but I love this idea of parallel
processing using chat posting it on the
board writing it up I think that can be
really helpful a little bit of the
opposite how do you shut people down who
are talking too much who are sucking the
air out of the room how do you get them
to quiet down to allow others to
contribute You've Got To Boldly raise
your hand hand and say oh my goodness
I'm noticing the time yeah so use the
time or use the goals that you have to
achieve as the mechanism absolutely I
also rely here on paraphrasing too where
you can literally interrupt the person
by highlighting something of value they
said and then politely moving the
conversation over so I might say at
least that point you made about cost
really important I'm wondering what does
Neil think about cost and all of a
sudden I've taken the floor away so I
think you're right you have to call it
blame it on timing blame it on the goal
use
paraphrasing before we end Elise I'd
like to ask you the same questions I
asked everybody who joins me the first
question will be one I make up just for
you and then the other two are those
that are consistent across many guests
are you up for doing that Bring it on I
want you to reflect on the most recent
meeting that you were involved in either
as running or a participant what's one
thing that you would have done different
to make it more effective the clearer
you can be about your intent and exactly
what you want to have happen as you move
forward the more likely you are to get
it and in my last meeting I would have
taken the time upfront to be just even a
little bit
clearer all right so really having that
purpose and intent clearly defined and
aligned with everybody next question who
is a communicator that you admire and
why I like Anne Handley because she
makes me think she makes me laugh and
she makes me better what a wonderful
reason to like a communicator and I
encourage everybody to check out Ann's
work final question what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe I would
say deep breath to get clearer on that
intent open ears and a willingness to
keep in the
conversation so the deep breath to focus
makes a lot of sense to me open ears so
that you're listening in observing
what's going on talk to me about the
keeping in The Conversation Piece what
does that mean for you in the places
where communication is most likely to
break down I find is that sometimes it
breaks down because we're unwilling to
stick with it so people disengage when
it's uncomfortable or not in their
wheelhouse or they just don't want to
deal with it Ryan if first time you get
it wrong you walk away that is not a
successful communication recipe no not
at all not at all thank you for
clarifying and and I see how that is so
important you have to engage and you
have to participate even if it's
uncomfortable well Elise I knew this was
going to be an engaging conversation I
knew I would learn from you and all of
our listeners are benefiting from your
advice having a clear purpose in our
meetings focusing on the outcomes being
Equitable and open and demonstrating
what we want not just sharing what we
want really really important advice
thank you so much for for your time and
for your input and insight thanks for
inviting
me thank you for joining us for another
episode of think fast talks smart the
podcast from Stanford GSB to learn more
about effective meetings please listen
to episode number 42 with Sarah singer
and episode number 14 with Bob Sutton
this episode was produced by Jenny Luna
Ryan kampos and me Matt Abrahams our
music is from Floyd Wonder please please
find us on YouTube and wherever you get
your podcasts be sure to subscribe and
rate US also follow us on LinkedIn and
Instagram and check out faster smarter.
for deep dive videos English language
learning content and our
newsletter